اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
شابيني شقيقين برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في قريه بيت ريما شمال مدينه
رام الله صباح اليوم كذلك استشهد شهد شاب
فلسطيني متاثرا بجروحه واصيب نحو عشرين
خلال مواجهه وقعت فجر اليوم مع قوه
الاحتلال في بلده بيت امر شمال مدينه
الخليل في الضفه الغربيه
وقوات الاحتلال خلال اقتحام دوريات
العسكريه اضافيه للبلده لتامين خروج احدى
مركباتها العسكريه التي تعطلت خلال النشاط
عسكريا لها الليله الماضيه
وانا لفته نظركم لهذا الخبر الذي وردنا
للتو نقلا عن الخارجيه الفلسطينيه التي
تطالب محكمه الجنايات الدوليه والمجتمع
الدولي بتحمل المسؤوليه اذا تصاعد جرائم
الاحتلال الان ينضم الينا من رمضان مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري وليد اذن
التصعيد مستمر في الضفه وها هي اخر
المواقف الرسميه
ماذا في التفاصيل
جريمه قتل الشقيقين ظافر وجواد الريماوي
في بقريه كفر عين حيث كان بعد زياره
لعمتهم عائدين الى قريتهم المجاوره بيت
ريما تشير الى ان قوات الاحتلال تقوم بفتح
النار على الفلسطينيين بشكل عشوائي بهدف
القتل ايضا لان الشقيقين احدهما اصيب في
صدره والاخر كان قد اصيب في فخذه مما ادى
الى استشهادهم لاحقا وهما طالبين احدهما
خريج من جامعه بيرزيت التي نعتهما قبل
قليل وهذه الجريمه حسب الفلسطينيين تضافوا
الى مسلسل الجرائم كما قالت الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه المتواصله ضد المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وهناك حادثه قتل ايضا مواطن
فلسطيني ثالث في قريه بيت امر الفلسطينيه
يقولون انه كانت هناك مواجهات قوات
الاحتلال تدعي لان مواطنين هاجموا احدى
مركباتها التي اعطت في البلده لكن واضح
بان كل ذلك جرى خلال عمليات اقتحام تقوم
بها هذه القوات العديد من القرى والبلدات
الفلسطينيه على مستوى الردود الفعل
الفلسطينيه القوه الوطنيه والاسلاميه دعت
الى اضراب شامل اجلالا كما قالت للشهداء
الذين سقطوا في صباح اليوم والليله بنيران
قوات الاحتلال ودعت الى التصعيد ايضا وكان
هناك تصريح ايضا لافته امين سر لجنه
تنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين
الشيخ الذي وصف ما جرى بانه اعدام بدم
بارد وان جرائم الاحتلال المتواصله هذه
الردود وان كانت تذكر بالردود العاديه
التي تصدر في كل مره او التقليديه لكن
واضح بان هذا بسقوط الشهداء الثلاثه في
منطقه بيت ريما الشماليه رام الله الشمالي
مدينه الخليل يرتفعت مجموع عدد الشهداء
الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام بنيران
القوات الاحتلال الى 205 الشهداء
معظمهم في الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله
وهناك 52 شهيدا في قطاع غزه سقطوا خلال
الحرب الاخيره هذا التصعيد من وجهه نظر
الفلسطينيين ينذروا بان قوات الاحتلال
ماضيه في مسلسل جرائمها حسب ما اثمته
الجهات الرسميه وايضا الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وهو ما يستدعي تدخل عاجلا من قبل المجتمع
الدولي وخاصه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه من
اجل وضع حد باستمرار المسلسل عمليات القتل
لكن اللافت فعلا فيما جرى صباحا هذا اليوم
هو جريمه قتل الشقيقين ظافر وجواد الرماوي
اللذين فتحت عليهما قوات الاحتلال النيران
دون سابق انذار وان كانت قد تزرعت بانها
كانت في عمليه قد انهت عمليه اعتقالات في
المنطقه وفي طريق انسحابها تعرق تعرضت
لرشق للحجاره لكن الشقيقين ظافر وجواد
الرماوي قتل بدم بارد من وجهه نظر
الفلسطينيين وان القوات الاحتلال فتحت
عليهم النيران دون ان تكون هناك ايه
مواجهات العمري